the friday prayers have uh just finished
the what which is the body that controls
overseas the al-aqsa compound estimated
around 150 000 muslims came to worship
uh this afternoon
uh at the moment it's been very peaceful
uh which is obviously good news there
are still more to leave alexa compound
uh there's been quite a lot of in the
pictures we've seen from inside a lot of
max flags being waived the israeli
police knights is provocative hamas the
militant organization which controls
gaza
and
israel's traditional enemy they have
called for resistance and they've called
for palestinians to defend al-aqsa
mosque and that is in part why we have
seen some of the violence there this
morning as i say at the moment it's
peaceful the authorities will hope that
it remains that way but this morning uh
palestinians throwing rocks and
fireworks
at israeli police after dawn prayers
israeli police responded
with
tear gas rubber bullets stun grenades
at least 30 palestinians were wounded in
that one israeli policewoman received
life injuries as well from a rock that
was thrown at her and struck her but at
the moment uh here down to massachusetts
getting some of the focal point uh it is
peaceful it is peaceful in atlanta
compound if we just quickly swing the
camera around fine to show you um
there's some securities in place i mean
that police outpost up there is a
permanent structure
but policing here and the security
operation is far far more enhanced uh
than it would otherwise be
because of the tensions and because of
the violence that we've seen in our
accents